Traduttore: Marco Caresia
Revisore: Andrea Giglio
Carla: Immaginate di essere nell'oscurità,
davanti a voi una parete di roccia.
Adesso nel buio infilatevi l’imbragatura,
cercate i primi appigli
e arrivate fino al primo chiodo
e poi al secondo e via via fino in cima.
Difficile?
Forse.
Diciamo che ci vuole molta immaginazione.
Giulia: Sono abbastanza tesa, panico,
so che appena metterò su il piede
mi verrà il panico.
Perché tanto è sempre così.
C: No, no.
G: No ma è sempre così
perché io poi sono carica,
cioè, le cose me le sento,
poi però quando veramente sono lì
dopo inizia lo spauracchio più totale.
Sono in panico, non riesco più.
Calma.
Prossima è la catena?
Ma dov'e?
Vai verso destra, sali.
Gira tutto.
(Rumore di gancio)
G: Sì. Trovata.
C: Brava.
G: Adesso sarà un dramma qua.
C: Respira, Giulia!
OK, vai ancora un po’.
Vai.
G: Non ci riesco.
C: La corda... Ecco, vai!
G: No...
C: Dai ragazzi ma qui c’è lo schermo,
il pubblico è alle nostre spalle.
Ragazzi: Porca miseria, iniziamo bene!
(Applausi)
C: Ecco evidenti tracce di disabilità.
Anche qua.
G: Ciao io sono Giulia
e sono quella che avete appena sentito
nella disperazione più totale.
Volete sapere com'è andata
a finire quella volta?
Be', quella volta è andata bene,
sono arrivata in cima e ho messo la corda
in catena come diciamo noi arrampicatori.
Qui ero in roccia ma normalmente
faccio arrampicata sportiva
su parete artificiale.
Sono agonista nella categoria B2, ovvero
la categoria degli ipovedenti molto gravi.
Matteo: Dai, ma come fai ad arrampicare
che non vedi gli appigli?
G: C’è Carla che mi dà le indicazioni,
lei legge per me il tracciato dal basso
e la sua voce mi accompagna di presa
in presa durante tutto il percorso,
e, per evitare di urlare a squarciagola,
utilizziamo degli auricolari
con un microfono.
Il metodo di guida
che abbiamo sviluppato negli anni
è piuttosto complesso e si basa
fondamentalmente sul quadrante
dell'orologio per muovere le mani,
mentre per i piedi utilizziamo
anche le parti del corpo.
Adesso ve lo facciamo vedere.
C: Allora bionda, abbiamo
quattro pannelli in verticale
e altri quattro pannelli
in leggero strapiombo.
Prima presa di partenza:
parti accoppiando qua
e hai piede sinistro e ginocchio sinistro,
poi avrai un altro piede
qui all’anca e vai a undici.
Poi fai una, incrocino a una
e di nuovo una. OK?
G: OK.
C: Quando sei pronta a parti.
C: Piede sinistro ginocchio sinistro,
ore undici.
Piede destro ginocchio destro,
una. Incrocino a una.
Piede sinistro a ginocchio destro,
e destro esterno ginocchio destro
e una di nuovo.
(Applausi)
In realtà il metodo di guida
è abbastanza complesso,
ma dopo anni di allenamento
e di lavoro insieme
io e Carla ci intendiamo alla perfezione.
Lei conosce bene
il mio stile di arrampicata
e io so decodificare con precisione
le sue indicazioni
che debbono essere il più possibile
rapide e sintetiche.
Poi sta a me tradurle
sulla parete di arrampicata
utilizzando la tecnica giusta.
A me piace molto la sensazione
di leggerezza e di autonomia
che provo quando mi muovo in verticale.
Arrampico da sei anni
e dal 2012 faccio parte
della squadra nazionale di paraclimbing.
Ho esordito a 15 anni ai campionati
del mondo di Parigi
conquistando la medaglia di bronzo
e altre ne sono seguite.
L'ultima è di colore argento
ed è arrivata a luglio di quest'anno
ai Campionati Europei di Chamonix.
(Applausi)
M: Ma per te Giulia l’arrampicata cosa è?
Per me l'arrampicata è
una via sempre nuova,
una via che mi conduce
verso qualcosa di misterioso,
non importa vedere cos'è,
mi basta percepirlo.
E voi ragazzi cosa ci fate qui?
M: Sono Matteo, anch'io non ci vedo e,
come Giulia, sono atleta di paraclimbing,
così si chiama l'arrampicata
praticata da atleti con disabilità.
Mi alleno a Bologna e sono campione
del mondo di velocità.
Sono stato nel 2011 anche
campione del mondo di difficoltà.
La velocità è una specialità
di arrampicata sportiva
su parete artificiale
ed è la specialità veloce,
per intenderci,
mentre la difficoltà è una specialità
che richiede padronanza della tecnica,
capacità d'improvvisazione
e di interpretazione del tracciato.
In questa specialità, stando
ai risultati, riesco piuttosto bene.
Quest'anno a Chamonix
mi sono laureato Campione Europeo.
(Applausi)
Io gareggio della categoria B1,
che è quella, per intenderci,
di chi non vede proprio niente.
G: E tu, Matteo, come fai ad arrampicare
in velocità che non ci vedi?
M: Nella velocità posso scatenare tutta
la mia esplosività, come un centometrista.
Personalmente corro sul tracciato
omologato alto 10 metri con 19 prese.
Lo conosco a memoria così posso correre
in verticale in piena autonomia.
Il mio record personale sul tracciato
omologato è di 8 secondi e 41.
(Applausi)
G: Ma quando fai difficoltà,
anche tu sei guidato?
M: Sì, anch’io quando faccio difficoltà
sono guidato da Carla.
Fin da bambino mi divertivo ad arrampicare
su grandi massi oppure,
un po' più da grande,
in montagna con mio padre.
Dell'arrampicata mi è sempre piaciuta
la sensazione di libertà che si prova.
Con Carla ho iniziato nel 2008.
G: Per te Matteo l’arrampicata cosa è?
M: Per me l’arrampicata è un istinto.
Un istinto di rabbia,
un istinto di libertà,
un istinto di calma, tenacia, pacatezza,
un istinto d’opposti,
un istinto che esplode,
un istinto che scorre leggero
al servizio della parte migliore
che c'è in ognuno di noi.
G: E tu moro?
Giulio: Ciao sono Giulio.
Anch'io sono un atleta di paraclimbing
e come Giulia gareggio nella categoria B2.
Ho iniziato proprio
insieme a lei nel 2009.
Tu, Matteo, arrampicavi già.
Ci hai ispirati,
così abbiamo incominciato.
Anch'io ho faccio gare di velocità
e di difficoltà,
ma la difficoltà la preferisco,
perché i tracciati sono sempre diversi
e c’è sempre una sfida nuova
dove mi metto alla prova,
difficoltà dopo difficoltà,
dovendo trovare rapidamente
soluzioni di successo,
e quando un passaggio non mi riesce
ci provo e ci riprovo
finché non trovo la soluzione giusta.
(Applausi)
Non esiste rinuncia.
L'arrampicata mi tempra e mi permette
anche di affrontare gli obiettivi
della vita con entusiasmo
e determinazione,
e il bello è soprattutto il condividere
tutto ciò con voi, con gli amici.
Anch'io mentre arrampico
sono guidato da Carla.
Ehi ragazzi,
se sono qui, se siamo qui, è perché noi
facciamo parte della stessa squadra.
G: Ma, allora, secondo te,
noi siamo coraggiosi?
G: Qualcuno dice che lo siamo,
ma ogni tanto anche noi abbiamo paura,
soprattutto quando arrampichiamo
in roccia,
ma la paura è una parete che deve
essere superata come tutte le altre.
G: E tu Carla che cosa ci fai qui?
C: Dai, ragazzi, anche io faccio parte
Della squadra se no voi chi vi sta dietro?
(Applausi)
G: Ma non facevi l’avvocato tu?
C: Eh, sì, l'ho fatto per 24 anni.
Poi, ad un certo punto, mi sono accorta
che, come avvocato,
avevo esaurito ogni curiosità,
che non mi identificavo più
in quello che facevo.
Così prevaleva un senso di compressione
troppo forte, che non tolleravo più.
La sera invece, quando ero in palestra
come istruttrice di arrampicata,
stavo bene e quello negli ultimi anni
era diventato l'obiettivo
delle mie giornate.
Ma avevo un’alternativa molto valida,
così ho deciso di cambiare,
anzi di andare oltre e di seguire
la mia onda, come la chiamo io.
M: Certo che hai avuto un bel coraggio
a ripartire da zero.
C: Ragazzi, per cambiare un po’,
bisogna buttarcisi
con curiosità e positività
e bisogna azzerare il contachilometri.
Si riparte da zero è vero,
ma il bagaglio è pieno,
così come quando in cima alla parete
si torna terra e da terra si riparte
per quella successiva.
Poi voi eravate giovanissimi,
mi avete dato una forte spinta.
Il lavoro che facevo con voi attirava
e attraeva la mia curiosità,
era una continua esplorazione,
una continua scoperta,
una nuova sfida che mi ha appassionato
e mi ha preso.
Poi sono anche successe cose
che mi hanno fatto riflettere su chi sono,
cosa voglio, e così ho capito
che la mia parte nella avvocatura
si era esaurita e che con voi
era iniziata una nuova avventura umana,
una nuova sfida che mi ha appassionato
e mi ha preso, capace di rinnovare
potentemente i miei entusiasmi.
Be’, dai, non mi sono sbagliata,
insieme abbiamo fatto tante cose,
abbiamo fatto scoperte sorprendenti,
tanti incontri impensati.
Siamo cresciuti e tanto.
Oggi siamo una vera squadra,
accresciuta nella consapevolezza
e dalla partecipazione di Fede e di Pietro
che abbiamo incontrato, due grandi,
che abbiamo incontrato
lungo questa parete invisibile
e che hanno deciso di stare con noi
e che anche stasera sono qui con noi
e che salutiamo.
Ragazzi: Ciao ragazzi!
(Applausi)
Noi siamo gli occhi
e voi le braccia e le gambe.
Abbiamo imparato muoverci in sincronia
e a metterci in gioco
con fiducia reciproca,
e solamente accettando il rischio
di non farcela, insieme,
possiamo arrivare in cima.
Per cui la prossima volta
che voi sarete di fronte
alla vostra parete da superare al buio,
G: anche se avrete la fortuna di incontrare
una persona di cui fidarvi,
che sia la vostra guida,
G: ricordatevi che le mani
che stringeranno gli appigli
saranno le vostre
M: e se vi capiterà di aver paura
non rinunciate!
La paura sarà solo
un’altra parete da superare.
(Applausi)